all right so that's it for the
family-wise error rate and now we're
going to move on to a topic called the
false discovery rate which is sort of a
more contemporary take on multiple
testing
so it really goes back to this table
where remember this corresponds to the
possible outcomes for m hypothesis tests
that we've conducted
and we can control for each hypothesis
test which row we're in because we know
how many hypotheses have been rejected
and how many null hypotheses we haven't
rejected but we don't ever know what the
values in the columns are because the
columns correspond to the ground truth
which of course we don't have access to
so the family-wise error rate focuses on
controlling the probability that v is
greater than one the probability of
falsely rejecting any null hypothesis
and in garrett's example of a criminal
defendant again this corresponds to the
idea
of having m defendants on trial
and v
is the event that we falsely convict
someone who's innocent that's really bad
so the family-wise error rate is what
we've been talking about so far we want
it to be small
but the issue is that in a lot of
settings we're not actually dealing with
potentially
sending someone to prison for a crime
they didn't commit in a lot of settings
we might be okay occasionally having a
type one error
and the reason we might be okay with the
type 1 error is because trying to avoid
any type 1 errors like the family-wise
error rate is doing might just be too
tough of an ask when m is large yeah it
might involve just us never rejecting
anything right and so again in the case
of a criminal defendant that might be
okay because maybe the cost of falsely
convicting even one person is just a
cost that we're not willing to bear but
there are other settings where we might
be able to occasionally make some type
one errors in exchange for being able to
reject a larger number of null
hypotheses
so that leads to this idea called the
false discovery rate and the false
discovery rate or the fdr is the
expectation of v divided by r so if we
look at this table
r is the total number of null hypotheses
we reject and v is the subset of those
rejected null hypotheses for which the
null hypothesis actually holds so those
are the errors
so the fdr is just
the fraction of the rejected null
hypothesis that were actually true that
we actually shouldn't have rejected
and that e notation means that this is
an expectation on average we we
might have a false discovery rate of say
what would a good number be here 20
let's say 20
and so that would indicate that of all
the null hypotheses we rejected
we expect about 20 of those uh to be
false discoveries and 80 of them to be
correct discoveries so this idea of
false discovery rate is useful in some
applications and not others so again um
in a in a
the context of a criminal defense um
setting we would be really really
unhappy
if 20 of the people who we convicted
were actually innocent like that is
clearly not going to be okay but there's
some other settings where a false
discovery rate could make sense so for
example let's say that you're a
scientist
and you're testing m drug targets where
m is maybe 10 000
um to see if they might be um useful
against uh
i don't know hypothetically a virus
that's caused a um huge pandemic the
last 18 months hypothetically
um
and you don't want to have too many
false positives but on the other hand
you might be okay with the false
discovery rate of 20
because any drug target that seems
promising against covid you're gonna of
course follow up on in the lab
extensively so that's the setting where
you'd be okay with um having a larger
number of type one errors in exchange
for having a lot of drug targets that
you can do follow-up investigation on
but you don't want too many type 1
errors you want that false discovery
rate to be capped at maybe 20 or 10
percent depending on how many resources
your lab has to to follow up on those
drug targets yep
all right so the false discovery rate
it's the expectation of this ratio which
is the number of false rejections
divided by the total number of
rejections we have 20 000 drug
candidates we want to identify a smaller
set of promising candidates to
investigate further
but we don't want the smaller set of
promising candidates to have too much
garbage we want some assurance that that
that set of quote-unquote promising drug
candidates really is promising so we
want the fdr to be not too big
in the setting family-wise error rate
really isn't the right thing because
family-wise error rate would help the
scientists be sure
that
no
drug targets are false positives but
again some false positives are okay
the reality is that if you try to
control the family-wise zero rating in
that setting you probably just end up
finding nothing that's right exactly
because 20 000 is a really big number
all right so it turns out that there's a
really i don't want to say easy way to
control the fdr because as you'll see
it's sort of a little bit unintuitive
but let's just say a very uh clearly
defined procedure that's actually going
to allow us to control the fdr and this
is called on benjamini hochberg
and i think that um one of the videos as
part of this online course actually may
possibly include an interview with ben
giamini
so here's the idea between behind the
benjamini hawkwood procedure first
you're going to specify q that's the
level at which to control the false
discovery rate so when we were talking
about type 1 error and family-wise error
rate we usually use alpha as our letter
and now our letter is going to be q
and now we're going to compute p values
for each of our m null hypotheses
we're going to order those p values
where again p sub 1 with the parentheses
indicates the smallest of the mp values
and p sub m indicates the largest of the
mp values
so so far this looks a lot actually like
that home procedure that gareth showed
us
and now i'm going to define l and l is
going to be the largest value of j
such that the jth smallest p-value is
less than q j over m
oh goodness gareth that's quite a
mouthful yeah that's why i let you
present it right now
so
again it's the largest value of j
such that the j smallest null hypothesis
is less than q which is my fdr threshold
like maybe 0.1 or something times j
divided by m where m is the number of
null hypotheses
and then we're going to reject all of
the null hypotheses
that have p values smaller than p sub l
so p values smaller than the l smallest
p value
and if we do this procedure then
through magic the false discovery rate
is going to be less than or equal to q
it's not really magic
statistical theory statistical theory
should we call it that okay so the fdr
is going to be less than or equal to q
i'll say the argument for why bon
ferroni procedure works gareth showed it
to us it was a couple of lines the
argument for why the benjamini hoffman
procedure works is is more involved
all right so in this slide we can sort
of see
what happens if we compare the false
discovery rate to the family wise error
rate and this is an example where we
have a whole bunch of p-values in
particular 2000 p-values for m equals
2000 null hypotheses and here the
p-values have been ordered
from smallest to largest so the x-axis
indexes those ordered p values and the
y-axis shows you the value of the
p-value on the log scale
and suppose that we want to control the
family-wise error rate at level alpha
equals 0.1 using a bonferroni correction
well that corresponds to rejecting any
null hypotheses for which the p-value is
below the green line so you can see that
horizontal green line that corresponds
to 0.1 divided by 2000
remember this is the y-axis is on the
log scale
and we can see that none of these 2000
p-values fall below the green line
that's disappointing it's very
disappointing it's like you know we put
in all this money to conduct the study
we tested two thousand things
and we're unable to reject any of them
at an fw er at a false family-wise error
rate of level alpha equals 0.1 so it's
very sad even though some of those
p-values look pretty small they do look
pretty small don't they yeah i'm feeling
really disappointed actually by this
finding lack of finding you can't
publish a paper on this
but
if instead we think about the false
discovery rate
if we control the level uh the false
discovery rate at level 0.1 or 10 with
benjamini hackberg then that amounts to
rejecting all of the null hypotheses
that are shown in blue
and you can see
that's a whole bunch of blue null
hypotheses or rather a whole bunch of
p-values
corresponding to null hypotheses that
we're going to reject
so what's going on here um well if you
look at that red line and we go back to
the benjamini hochberg procedure
the red line corresponds to a line with
slope
q over m and that's because if you look
at step four here i want to find the
largest value of j such that the the p
value is less than q j over m
so this red line has slope q over m
and what i want is the largest p-value
index
such that the p-value falls below that
red line and that actually is right here
can you see that it's like the
the right-most blue point so that's why
the blue points are all here is because
these are the p-values that are less
than the elf largest p value where here
l is
the last time
that a p value falls below that red line
so using benjamin hopper we were able to
reject a lot of null hypotheses gary
this is really great but remember fdr it
seems like a win because it allowed us
to reject a lot more null hypotheses but
the guarantees that we're getting are
really different so again with the
family-wise error rate we're saying
we're not willing to make any mistakes
or rather we we want no more than a 10
chance of having any false positives and
with fdr i'm like hey false positives
are fine like i'm cool with false
positives please just don't give me too
many i don't want more than 10
of my discoveries to be false
all right
so we can go back actually to the fun
data where we have these five p values
we order them again so the smallest is
0.006 the largest is 0.918 and we can
think about applying benjamini hackberg
so
we need to compare the smallest p-value
to 0.05 over 5. the second smallest
p-value to 2 times 0.05 over 5. the
third to 3 times .05 over 5 the fourth
to 4 times 0.05 over 5 and finally the
fifth gets compared just to 0.05 and
then we need to look for the largest
index such that the p-value is less than
the threshold that we're comparing it to
and we see that for p1 and for p2 those
p-values are smaller than the threshold
but starting with the third smallest
p-value the p-values actually exceed the
threshold so that means that we can only
reject the null hypothesis corresponding
to the two smallest p values
and again that corresponds to the first
and the third manager so we're going to
reject the first and the third null
hypothesis using benjamin hofberg at
level 0.05
great so this is actually an example
where um on this fun data
the
um
using fdr as opposed to
the home procedure did not lead to more
discoveries
but usually the time when we're going to
see a difference between fdr and
family-wise error rate is if m is really
really large and here m is pretty small
so we're not seeing much difference this
sort of is more like the classical
setting where something like family y0
array could make sense right so here uh
here on this slide we're seeing that um
using bonferroni and controlling the
family-wise air rate we only reject h
naught one but if you can recall from a
few slides ago when we used home to
control family-wise error rate we did
actually reject both the first and third
manager